[Música]
cómo avanzamos vamos con directo a y
llegamos a Ciudad de México para hablar
con nuestro corresponsal Mario carbonell
sobre la última reunión diplomática de
alto nivel mantenida entre el gobierno
de Estados Unidos y el de México en
Washington allí abordaron temas de
seguridad como el tráfico de armas y
también la migración en la frontera
compartida Mario qué más ha trascendido
de esta reunión mantenida entre ambos
estados
Así es se llevó a cabo este diálogo de
alto nivel en materia de seguridad en
donde se pusieron datos duros sobre la
mesa el canciller mexicano Marcelo
ebrard dijo que gracias a la
colaboración de los dos gobiernos de
México y Estados Unidos se ha logrado
decomisar casi 56.000 armas desde enero
de 2020 a la fecha tan solo este año se
han incautado 32.000 armas que han Pues
impedido que estén involucradas en
homicidios aquí en México se tiene
ubicados dijeron cuatro estados que son
los más grandes proveedores de armas a
los grupos criminales California Arizona
Texas y Connecticut y 10 condados de
estos estados a su vez el secretario de
estado Anthony blinken dijo Bueno él
puso énfasis en lo que más les aqueja a
los estadounidenses que es el tráfico de
drogas habló de los 110.000 muertes por
sobredosis en Estados Unidos de los
cuales 75 entre 70 y 75% están
vinculadas al fentanilo es en ese
sentido que Pues pusieron el acento y la
disposición de trabajar para avanzar en
erradicar estas dos problemáticas que
aquejan a los dos países en un marco de
cooperación por otro lado Mario la
cámara de diputados aprobó con amplia
mayoría el cambio constitucional que
permitirá mantener al ejército con
tareas de Seguridad Ciudadana hasta el
año 2028 una medida que ha sido
controvertida por el historial de
excesos militares del país con qué
apoyos ha sacado el gobierno o la medida
y bajo qué argumento se ha promovido
fue una iniciativa curiosamente
impulsada presentada por el pri el
partido del ex presidente Peña Nieto y
que de inmediato fue abrazada por el
partido Morena del actual presidente
López Obrador y fue posible la
aprobación gracias a un intenso cabildeo
del secretario de gobernación hagan
Augusto López para conseguir los votos
precisamente de todos los priístas
porque no todos estaban de acuerdo y
también de otro partido el PRD que si
bien está disminuido contribuyó a la
aprobación de esta reforma que como bien
dices es controvertida el gobierno
argumenta que es necesaria la presencia
de las fuerzas más para combatir a la
criminalidad todavía un tiempo más
porque no están suficientemente
capacitadas las policías en los Estados
y la oposición pues alega que es una
medida que demuestra el fracaso de la
política de seguridad y que solamente va
a provocar una mayor militarización y
posible violación de Derechos Humanos la
ya aprobada por las dos cámaras ahora
está en una gira por los congresos
estatales 17 de ellos tienen que
avalarla para que se pueda ya promulgar
y entrar en vigor